uh let's go to isaac from ohio next
isaac from ohio you're on the air
oh god hello how are you good
what can i do for you so uh forgive me
if this is completely incorrect because
he's not taking a single economic class
or anything okay
but uh i know that
you're you're like a social democrat
you're not in favor of like full-blown
socialism
right but um i came up with an idea a
little while back
what if um instead of like
outlawing like capitalism to go to
socialism because that would be too
complicated it's like
i don't i don't know what if we take um
what if we like defined uh like
wage slavery properly okay and outlawed
that
like you couldn't just like the common
practice of
just hiring someone paying them a flat
rate for their labor
where they have no ownership of their
workplace if we like
at least gave workers some ownership of
their workplace in all cases
so you're saying somebody kind of some
kind of law
that says every employee must be given
partial ownership of their place of
employment
yeah i don't see how you get that done
legally i mean i i don't i don't even
know that it's
i i think that the way to do it so that
would be a very authoritarian imposition
and
check out my interview with the uh with
the youtuber
vosh who is a socialist but he said that
the way that
as he sees it the way you're going to
implement these things
is going to be by convincing businesses
and others
that it's a good idea for them to do it
rather than imposing it as law that
that i i hope i'm not wrong in
summarizing his perspective that way but
even he said that the types of things
you're talking about are very
authoritarian and
would essentially be uh dead ends um and
and i think that he's probably right
about that i think what you're
suggesting would be very
would essentially be impossible to do
you would just be saying
you you would be mandating you were
trying to force companies to do things
that there's no legal basis to force
them to do
it's less about economics it's more
about the law
okay you're just you're not particularly
against something like that you're just
saying it's not um
realistically possible so as a so as a
social democrat i'm not in favor of what
you're describing but for me it's not
even really the main issue because it's
just
you're you're not going to get it done
in the in the way where there's just a
law passed and it says
all employees are now owners
yeah well i'm not trying to make it that
simple like what if
if uh we say like the lowest tier of
workers have to own
like at least 20 of the entire company
collectively like is
is that something that could work or i
don't see how i don't see how you get it
passed i mean i think the
the more important thing would be to for
you to think about this less as an
economic thing but more as a
how do you how do you get what is the
legal structure where you could do that
where government could do that
is it federal and is it state and if
it's one versus the other how do you
actually do it
and i i just don't see it i think if i
were you i would focus on how you get it
done rather than whether it's a good
idea i just don't see how you ever
how you ever get that done yeah i see
that's a really good point
yeah all right my friend though i
appreciate the call
yeah thank you all right pleasure uh
let's take a couple of others because
there
are many people many many people
who want to chat if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an ebook
or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video